y
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el 22 de
marzo es la fecha que conmemora el día
mundial del agua una fecha que tiene
como objetivo concientizar acerca de la
crisis del agua a nivel mundial y la
necesidad que tenemos de buscar medidas
para hacerle frente y así poder alcanzar
el objetivo de desarrollo sostenible
número 6 es decir agua y saneamiento
para todos antes del 2030 no sobra
recordar la importancia del agua en
nuestra vida diaria es un líquido
esencial y una gran cantidad de
actividades económicas y sociales
dependen completamente del
abastecimiento de agua dulce agua que no
siempre es potable o no siempre tiene
buena calidad debido al mal uso que
también le estamos dando nosotros cerca
de 2.200 millones de personas viven sin
acceso a agua potable en pleno siglo 21
en pleno siglo cuando la humanidad ha
alcanzado un nivel de desarrollo
tecnológico sin precedentes aunque tener
suministro de agua es un privilegio para
muchos el planeta tiene cerca de mil 386
millones de kilómetros cúbicos
agua pero la mayoría del agua que
tenemos es salada solo el 0 0 0 7% del
agua del planeta es agua potable
pues cada año el día del agua es
conmemorado con un foco o con un tema
principal para el 2022 la atención está
enfocada en las aguas subterráneas es
decir aguas que están bajo tierra en
acuíferos en formaciones de roca arena o
de barro que contienen considerables
cantidades de agua que pueden ser
aprovechadas por la humanidad eso sí
aprovechadas para su buen uso
la coyuntura internacional actual es
decir el marco de la pandemia del cobi
19 que todavía seguimos combatiendo dejó
sobre la mesa la importancia del agua
para poder frenar precisamente las
epidemias pandemias o enfermedades
infecciosas lavarse las manos es
fundamental para cortar la transmisión
del cob y 19 o de otro tipo de
enfermedades por eso hoy en el debate de
france 24 el día mundial del agua un
recurso vital bajo amenaza ese es
nuestro tema y lo vamos a analizar en
unos minutos con nuestros invitados
entre ellos esta verónica arias ellas
experta en medio ambiente también es
directora ejecutiva de la coalición de
ciudades capitales de las américas
frente al cambio climático ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de quito en
ecuador y desde santiago en chile se
conecta a esta conversación víctor durán
ribera él es líder del proyecto
vigilantes del lago e integrante de la
red mundial de lagos living lakes
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden hacer parte de esta conversación
y hacer todo tipo de preguntas y
comentarios lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook también en instagram y en
twitter estamos como
24s santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
y les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es
numeral del debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionados con este tema comienzo con
veronica en la ciudad de quito
preguntándole por la situación actual
precisamente esta fecha sirve para hacer
balance de cómo está la situación en
cuanto al agua al manejo del agua los
recursos hídricos que tenemos en el
planeta que para algunos países son muy
comunes sobre todo para los países que
estamos en el trópico pero para otros en
zonas desérticas el agua es un bien
preciado y difícil y escaso cómo está la
situación de las fuentes hídricas
hídricas y de las fuentes de agua
potable
gracias gracias santiago por
estos momentos y tan importante en este
momento decir que no estamos muy bien
que digamos cuando hablamos de agua
significa también hablar de calidad y
cantidad y en términos de acceso no
solamente de agua potable fíjate que dos
millones dos mil doscientos millones de
personas viven sin acceso de agua
potable cuando el mundo está con la
tecnología hablamos con hablamos de
temas tan importantes como
inteligencia artificial
estamos hablando de conquistar el
espacio cual y todavía no tenemos cosas
básicas como estos no y por otro lado
tenemos un desbalance y es parte de los
ecosistemas
el problema es que los ecosistemas están
siendo afectados de manera grave
especialmente en las partes donde se
produce esa agua en calidad y en
cantidad entonces lo que llega
finalmente a las ciudades oa las cuencas
bajas es realmente ya un agua de mala
calidad o contaminada
justamente por la contaminación de suelo
que termina siendo pues contaminando a
los acuíferos no a los acuíferos ahora
que estamos hablando del tema de aguas
subterráneas en definitiva hay un
desbalance en términos generales en
términos mundiales más aún cuando
sabemos que el menos del 1 por ciento
del agua dulce en el mundo es ésta es
poquísima y está simplemente en ciertas
partes y empresas en los polos no que
están gravemente afectados por el tema
de cambio climático víctor durán en la
ciudad de santiago en chile su
perspectiva de la situación de las
fuentes hídricas de la disponibilidad de
agua para la humanidad el acceso que
tenemos a ella y la calidad que tenemos
del agua en nuestras ciudades o también
en nuestras zonas rurales
bueno indudablemente que es muy
preocupante en su novela las cifras
contundentes
que señalan a ser de unidad en el
objetivo número 6 que tuviera lo
señalaba
es realmente preocupante tanto a la
gente que no tiene acceso al agua
potable como también que no tienen al
saneamiento hay meses de ciertas
personas que hacen sus necesidades
biológicas o básicas en el campo abierto
y eso indudablemente que establecería
enfermedades a esa población en el caso
de chile estaban en un proceso justo
hace poco en la cumbre climática en los
26 en cloud glasgow escocia y es
contraproducente que chile es un país
que produce sólo un 0 25 por ciento de
los gases efecto invernadero no obstante
está dentro de los 10 países más
perjudicados por el cambio climático y
la escasez hídrica sobre todo al norte
del país es muy fuerte se está pensando
en desalinizar el agua para poder
abastecer
población humana no
quería aportar un dato aquí importante
pues no sólo trabajamos con lagos a
nivel no tan sólo en chile sino que a
nivel internacional latinoamérica
concierto de él sólo el 2 por ciento del
agua dulce está disponible en forma
inmediata y de ese 2 por ciento sólo no
está en el 90 por ciento es agua está
presente en los lagos lagunas y los
embalses de la importancia de cuidar y
proteger este importante recurso hídrico
cuál es la estrategia
que el ibex y nosotros propiciamos
probablemente que tiene que ser la
planificación por cualquier o gráfica
maneje entre el agua en caso es
relevante y clave
en segundo lugar tener autoridades de
cuenca organismos que se hagan cargo de
protegiendo hoy día más así en los
países latinoamericanos o en chile hay
mucha normativa dispersa hay mucha
autoridades que se hacen los
que deben hacerse cargo del agua y no
hay una adecuada donde la gente
coordinación víctor continuó con usted
quiero preguntarle es por la fecha esta
fecha 22 de marzo fecha para conmemorar
el día mundial del agua es lamentable
que todavía tengamos que tener una fecha
que nos recuerde la importancia del agua
sigue la humanidad sin ser completamente
consciente de lo que está haciendo en
malgastar este recurso al explotar
también de manera indiscriminada los
recursos que tiene para poder acceder a
agua dulce que puede ser consumida por
los seres vivos los seres humanos
estamos todavía muy lejos de ser
conscientes de lo que estamos usando y
desechando
bueno indudablemente el día del agua
se decreta por naciones unidas en la
cumbre de río en el año en brasil en el
año 92 en el año 93 que comienza esta
celebración
de este día del agua yo estuve en esa
cumbre también en el año 92
y se presionó mucho para que naciones
unidas
declarara este día como el día mundial
del agua precisamente como tú dices por
la falta de conciencia aún hay muy poca
conciencia respecto al agua recién ahora
en la zona por el cambio climático que
están quedando sin agua la idea política
de racionamiento en el caso de chile por
ejemplo hay camiones aljibes que llevan
agua para abastecer a poblaciones
enteras porque no hay agua y en santiago
se está pensando pues por la sequía en
tener que racionar el agua y colocar
impuestos al consumo del agua entonces
eso es un gran tema que a mi juicio
todavía nos falta mucho por llegar y por
generar políticas públicas que permitan
su producción es un término de calidad y
su cantidad clara veronica teniendo
claro este panorama que nos explica
víctor y que también aportaba usted
ideas al principio del programa que es
lo que está fallando entonces de parte
de nosotros de los seres humanos están
fallando los planes de educación en la
juventud para ser más conscientes sobre
el uso que le debemos dar al agua o
están fallando los programas a nivel
gubernamental y a nivel de las empresas
que también asumen algunos planes de
responsabilidad social corporativa y
asumen algunos planes y proyectos en
términos de medio ambiente en donde cree
usted que está la deficiencia
creo que hay varios varios factores que
tenemos de eficiencia y que tenemos que
abordar la primera es que el el ecuador
y creo que la mayoría de países de
américa latina tiene una legislación ya
caduca de principios de siglo que son
las leyes de agua mediante la
conformación de organizaciones sociales
alrededor del agua el tema de
concesiones y que hay que mirar desde un
factor integral integral en el sentido
de conservación y de manejo integrada de
una cuenca hídrica no solamente desde la
perspectiva del riego en base el cual la
organización social pues en creció no
sino que esa concepción ya es muy lejana
ya es
de principios del siglo anterior rosa ya
llevamos con esa legislación en la
mayoría de países la primera la segunda
es que tenemos una huella hídrica
importante a nivel de américa latina
y está por encima del promedio del
consumo entre 2.2
y en 3.2 por ciento de litros de agua en
diaria y eso significa que américa
latina por ser una región
pues de muchos recursos naturales
evidentemente del norte de chile y
también en algunos países ahí hay zonas
que ya tienen un estrés hídrico pero en
general es una región muy rica y también
un rica en agua y no hemos sentido esa
escasez que hay agua por decir de agua
por decirte en aplicado o en otros
países de asia entonces eso significado
que la gente simplemente abra la llave y
salga el agua y se duche pues horas de
horas sin saber que las áreas rurales
tienes que caminar como tres o cuatro
horas y especialmente las mujeres de los
niños para recoger esa agua para cocinar
y para lavar entonces eso significa que
tienes que tener un programa de
educación y de conciencia ambiental
importantísimo
para entender esa conexión que aguas
arriba y nos paramos en los glaciares se
produce el agua que no es gratuita que
tienes que mantener estos páramos que
tienes que conservar de donde se produce
el agua y no tienes que generar una
extensión de la frontera agrícola y
ganadera es un problema de deforestación
que va a afectar en la provisión de agua
no entonces hay varios factores que
están fallando veronica en américa
latina' dependiendo de lo que usted nos
está diciendo y de lo que nos
complementaba víctor hay algún país en
la región que esté siendo destacado en
cuanto a sus programas a sus políticas
medioambientales por el manejo que está
dando por las iniciativas que está
fomentando y cuáles son los que van
digamos más adelantados y cuáles están
digamos rezagados
bueno yo creo que hay ahí
excelentes aportes de varios países y yo
creo que más bien de ciudades y puedo
hablar por la de quitó porque vivo en
quito y conozco bien de cerca también
el caso de quito de medellín devota
donde se han creado por ejemplo los
fondos de agua que son que se crearon
hace 20 años y con la perspectiva de que
las empresas de agua potable no
solamente contribuyan o
cobren sus impuestos sino que parte de
esos impuestos van a la conservación de
la cuenca hidrográfica de dónde proviene
el agua y ha sido caso muy exitoso
porque vemos que los páramos se han
rehabilitado se han restaurado y la
ganadería ha bajado generando menos
impacto y los proyectos por ejemplo para
quitó de provisión de agua en calidad
siempre tenemos que hablar de calidad de
agua y de cantidad de agua se tiene
previsto que no tendrá ningún problema
para los próximos 40 años no entonces
son casos exitosos porque estás
previendo un mecanismo financiero pero
también de retribución al ecosistema de
dónde estás sacando el agua lo mismo
tiene bogotá hay lo mismo tiene mexico y
algún par de mas
víctor usted se encuentra en santiago en
la capital de chile usted lo mencionaba
este país se presenta serios problemas
de abastecimiento en el norte es una
zona desértica está el desierto de
atacama hay muchos problemas de
abastecimiento allí pero es un país que
resulta paradójico porque el sur es una
zona en donde se presentan muchas
precipitaciones a lo largo del año
también tienen los grandes campos de
hielo en el sur de chile en el país
prácticamente presenta dos escenarios
completamente diferentes y opuestos
paradójicos que hacen las autoridades
chilenas para
fomentar el buen uso del agua educar a
los ciudadanos y sobre todo atender a
esa zona del norte que tiene tantas
complicaciones
bueno como tú dices es como
contradictorio no el país tiene
todos los climas en el caso del norte lo
que se está haciendo es
que las empresas mineras que son grandes
consumidores de agua dulce estén de
salinizando agua porque además pueden
tener energía eólica y energía solar
para generar para que la redundancia la
energía para desalinizar el auto 6 se
está generando toda la política pública
de manera de ir liberando estas aguas
dulces para el consumo humano también en
el caso de la agricultura pero en los
últimos años con el cambio climático ha
ido cambiando el clima en la zona
central
hace poco el chile aprobó la ley de
cambio climático y el primer país
latinoamérica que va a permitir tener
planes de planes de protección del agua
por cualquier gráfica lo cual nos parece
muy importante y más al sur la zona de
los lagos sólo tenemos 15.000 aulas una
en chile
se están generando políticas públicas
para generar planes de prevención y
descontaminación de nuestros lagos en
toda latinoamérica general mundial uno
de los principales problemas que están
teniendo nuestros lagos y lagunas
embalses también son los procesos
llamados de autorización es decir
ingresos de altas cantidades de
nitrógeno y fósforo
provenientes de distintos tipos de
actividades de urbanizaciones actividad
éticos las forestales ganaderas la
salmonicultura y otros que están
perjudicando esta importante fuente de
agua y de acuerdo a los informes que
nosotros tenemos en el caso del sur de
chile de quiera año 2050
todo nuestro de agua potable va a ser de
nuestro lado
por lo tanto de ahí viene la importancia
de generar normas de protección y es lo
que estamos trabajando como país para
poder tenerlas se también
estamos yendo más allá porque hay países
bastante avanzados en ordenación del
territorio planificación por cuenca
cuencas o méxico están haciendo un buen
trabajo ellos también en colombia
conocemos algunos casos nosotros
estuvimos en colombia en ecuador también
en fin salió vídeo la corriente a nivel
latinoamericano y mundial respecto a que
la única forma de poder proteger los
recursos hice web por cualquier o
gráfica como decía mi colega newen
mentido y con autoridades de cuenca
también corporaciones de la caja
administrar el recurso de lo contrario
vamos vamos en un fracaso produce
ustedes todos han hablado del
calentamiento global es un hecho es
evidente la situación en la que estamos
no solamente en cuanto al cuidado del
agua sino desde diferentes aspectos el
cambio climático está afectando
a día de la humanidad y precisamente el
cambio climático ha provocado
sequías ha provocado veranos más
intensos temporadas de lluvias más
cortas o temporadas de lluvias mucho más
fuertes inviernos más más prolongados o
mucho más fríos de lo habitual pero
también el siguiente invierno puede ser
más cálido de lo habitual el cambio es
evidente cómo ha afectado esto la
calidad del agua dulce que es la que
tenemos disponible para nuestro consumo
inmediato y que es la necesidad primaria
que tenemos como seres humanos veronica
el impacto del cambio climático en esta
situación
bueno el cambio climático está afectando
realmente a todo no a todo y eso
conlleva en el abastecimiento de agua y
de todos los recursos naturales en
general en términos de agua pues en
sitios donde veíamos que hay sequía los
procesos van a ser más fuertes cada vez
y donde vemos que hay precipitaciones
extremas pues van a ser así y más
fuertes entonces vemos imágenes por todo
lado de desbordamiento de ríos
impresionantes y por otros lados unas
olas de calor es impresionantes donde se
vuelve como un círculo virtuoso sino un
efecto más bien de círculo negativo
porque cuando tienes ola de calor
simplemente necesitas más agua
y tampoco hay agua entonces imagínate lo
que significa esto no hay un impacto
severo para el tema de los incendios
necesitas agua y justamente hay un
desabastecimiento de agua entonces que
es básicamente lo que hay que hacer hay
que mirar unos procesos de adaptación al
cambio climático para generar
resiliencia alos modelamiento futuros
que se vienen y que es el incremento de
la temperatura eso va a producir estrés
hídrico ya en zonas donde ya se están
viendo y eso va a significar una posible
migración
masiva que estamos viendo también desde
la parte rural hacia las ciudades y de
ciudades hacia otros países entonces se
significa seguridad alimentaria
significa que tenemos que mirar también
el tema de infraestructura no solamente
en la infraestructura gris no cómo va a
ser
visualizada la infraestructura
esto significa que hay acueductos tienen
que ser más grandes o qué tipo de la
infraestructura en ciudades vamos a
tener que tener sí y la infraestructura
verde eso es muy importante
infraestructura verde que genera y
resiliencia
víctor el tema de foco de este año de la
campaña para el día mundial del agua son
las aguas subterráneas
estamos hablando de aguas subterráneas
porque ya estamos llegando a un punto en
el que ya tenemos menos recursos y ya
tenemos que empezar a buscar lo que
tenemos en el subsuelo para poder
acceder a esas reservas de agua estamos
empezando a gastar digamos las pocas
reservas que nos queda o es simplemente
porque es importante hacer el llamado en
este momento para para que la gente
conserve estas cuencas acuíferas
subterráneas y las protejas de cara al
futuro como lo ve usted
bueno efectivamente
se está bien se están viendo
situaciones problemáticas importantes
porque estamos sacando más agua del
subsuelo de lo que el acuífero demora en
recargar recordemos que estos tipos de
acuíferos se recargan por la lluvia pero
también por la nieve por el hielo que se
acumulen dependiendo de dependiendo el
país pero si yo
empiezo a agotar estas capas de agua
empiezan a bajar y después no tengo agua
y es lo que está ocurriendo en muchas
partes que estos acuíferos se van se van
secando y la tasa de ocupación es mayor
que las de carguen más o menos 40 por
ciento estaba ocupada habana para la
agricultura y el cierto tipo de cultivo
que el caso de chile por ejemplo la
palta aguacate
depende del país
consume grandes cantidades de agua
también otro tipo de
frutas en fin entonces como decía mi
colega que tenemos que tener en esta
adaptación al cambio climático sin duda
ahí
reorientando activo de cultivo de
acuerdo a la zona y eso hay que
empezarlo a hacer desde ahora de manera
que aquí en un par de años tengamos
cultivos que consuman la menor cantidad
de agua posible y vamos a decir que
dejando ser tu hábitos digamos de
consumir grandes cantidades de palta
aguacate entonces es un temazo en
realidad un gran tema entre cómo nos
vamos a comportar en el futuro con
nuestra alimentación víctor y qué tan
que tan limpia es esa extracción del
agua subterránea porque algunos procesos
para poder extraer
en este caso el agua terminan siendo más
contaminantes y terminan generando otro
tipo de daños medioambientales
colaterales habló por ejemplo de la
extracción de petróleo a través del
fracking que termina haciendo un daño
ambiental un poco mayor que la
extracción habitual
en el sur de chile es
un poco la mayoría se traen de fuera
bueno en argentina que al lado también
sin duda que son son temas que tienen
que ver con mi derecha en la cop 26
hablo desde alguna manera y disminuyendo
a terminar con los subsidios algo a los
hidrocarburos
llegó un tema que no se logró no se
logró acuerdo tenemos que ir a avanzar
es una transición
de energías limpias energías renovables
como la solar energía
eólica mario moccia en fin hay varias
alternativas que debemos ir trabajando
para parar el dañando el acuífero en las
zonas agrícolas me ha tocado ver que las
capas de agua se contaminan por la
aplicación de herbicidas plaguicidas
también por fertilizantes que no tan
sólo el petróleo puede dañar las napas
subterráneas sino que también
actividades tan comunes como la como la
agricultura
veronica hay algún tipo de control hay
algún tipo de legislación de políticas
que controle el acceso a estos acuíferos
subterráneos que controlen este tipo de
extracción de agua o esto para el caso
de los países de américa latina donde
hay tanta abundancia de agua debido a
que muchos de los países están entre las
zonas tropicales y en zonas de selva no
hay ningún tipo de control y simplemente
quien quiera vaya extrae lo que quiera
extraer y cómo es este proceso
si la legislación es clara normalmente
en las leyes de agua también regula el
tema de acuíferos
el problema es básicamente el informe
del control en toda américa latina y ahí
tienes una temática muy fuerte que son
las concesiones las concesiones y las
relaciones que quiero decir con esto las
concesiones hay una sobre concesión es
decir sobre un mismo uso
tienes cuatro veces concesionado a la
empresa pues avícola a la empresa
bananera a la empresa y por último la
organización tal
en algunos países de américa latina y
hablo por el ecuador por ejemplo en la
constitución está claramente que se
establece una prelación el primero es
entender que es un derecho humano
de acceso al agua y el ser humano es
lo primero el privilegiado luego el
caudal ecológico sin caudal ecológico
simplemente no tienes ya el
suficiente
ambiente para que crezcan los peces y
los recursos que están dentro del agua y
luego debería ir justamente para el
sector productivo agrícola no hablar del
minero etcétera entonces si es que eso
funcionará así estaríamos bastante bien
la población pues y el mundo entero ha
crecido de diferente forma el primero
será la extracción porque necesita agua
en la minería necesita agua la
agricultura la ganadería necesita agua y
por último está el ser humano estamos
la pirámide está totalmente invertida
entonces el revertir todo esto significa
un cambio estructural muy fuerte
institucional muy fuerte con una
legislación que toca grandes intereses y
clark eso es lo que hay
veronica víctor sé que hemos hablado
desde puntos de vista tal vez muy
negativos y tal vez lo que estamos
diciendo acá es que estamos llegando
como a zonas de límites a zonas rojas de
eje del manejo que le estamos dando al
agua pero precisamente hay que hacer
este tipo de choques y este tipo de
llamados para que la gente tome
conciencia del uso que le estamos dando
a este recurso vital y uno de los
objetivos para el 2030 por parte de
naciones unidas y parte también de los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible que
es el número 6 justamente habla del agua
y habla de agua y saneamiento para todos
antes del 2030 cómo estamos vamos por
buen camino se nos está agotando el
tiempo y no estamos haciendo la tarea
como debe ser y vamos a llegar al 2030
en una situación peor de la que ya
estamos cuál es su opinión víctor
bueno el caso chileno
ha sido relativamente exitoso para zonas
urbanas no porque el modelo que se
implementó fue concesionar a empresas
privadas y la administración de la
producción del agua potable y su
tratamiento por lo tanto en chile está
cubierto más del 90% en la zona urbana
hay plantas tratamiento aguas servidas
si bien es cierto hay algunas plantas
que hay que mejorar por cierto pero pero
en gran medida las zonas urbanas tienen
tratamientos luego hacer vías no así en
otros países que me tocaba visitar en
latinoamérica
lo que estamos al día ve en las zonas
rurales todavía
como estas empresas concesionarias no
trabajan en zonas obviamente no les
conviene con obviamente las zonas
rurales más dispersas allí tenemos
problemas de saneamiento pero yo diría
que el caso chileno ha sido bastante
exitoso en ese sentido
estamos ya en la parte final del
programa verónica muy puntual por favor
quiero preguntarle por la tecnología
estamos en el siglo 21 en un momento en
que la humanidad ha desarrollado
tecnología
como nunca antes lo había visto a lo
largo de su historia en que la estamos
utilizando a nuestro favor para
garantizarnos tener agua dulce y poder
seguir existiendo acá como especie en el
planeta
pero seguro que hay tecnología hay
tecnología para rato pero tampoco es tan
barata estamos hablando por ejemplo de
procesos de desalinización
del agua salada no pero ya significa un
costo bastante alto especialmente para
nuestros países de américa latina es muy
alto podemos estar hablando con árabe
saudita que gasta un millón de dólares
en vez al iniciar para producir agua
potable para sus ciudades pero ese no va
a ser el caso de américa latina américa
latina está llamado más bien a conservar
lo que ya tiene que es gratuito entre
comillas y tal vez por eso es justamente
que desperdiciamos pero tenemos es a ese
gran asset y ese gran capital natural
que tiene que ser conservado más bien lo
que nos queda eso va a ser mucho más
barato entonces que tener que
potabilizar pues descontaminar
al iniciar el des desde es o reconstruir
siempre el principio es prevenir que
sale más barato y conservar lo que ya se
tiene que sale bastante más barato claro
para cerrar el programa víctor y
veronica
conclusiones de lo que viene para la
humanidad para américa latina en
particular en cuanto al manejo que le
está dando al agua las lecciones que
tenemos que aprender y las tareas a las
que nos tenemos que comprometer y
también les doy espacio para que hagan
un corto llamado para la audiencia de
france 24 en este día mundial del agua
comienzo entonces por víctor y dejó a
verónica para el cierre
bueno yo en lo personal creo que estoy
muy esperanzado con los colores nosotros
lo que hacemos es empoderar a la
comunidad como agentes de cambio para el
cuidado del agua de los lagos los
humedales a través del ciencia ciudadana
monitoreamos y así logramos generar
cambios con gobernanza si yo tengo fe
que que estos cambios están sucediendo
lentamente pero ésta están avanzando
sobre todo con nuestros jóvenes y el
llamado que yo hago es a cuidar el agua
también a generar políticas públicas
gobernadas a hacer un gran esfuerzo a
cumplir los objetivos de desarrollo
sustentable en particular como decía el
objetivo 6 y sobre todo involucrar mucho
a la comunidad cuando te involucras a la
comunidad desde abajo en los procesos de
ordenación del territorio manejen este
área de cuenca que es claro de vida
vamos a tener mejores resultados y que
yo lo personal soy optimismo optimista
mensajes positivos desde santiago y
verónica en la ciudad de quito su
conclusión y su mensaje
creo que estamos en un momento de
urgencia climática y de urgencia en
términos de recursos naturales creo que
siempre una jalada de orejas hace falta
para poder ser
proactivos y en este caso concuerdo
totalmente con víctor que la
organización cívica comunitaria es quizá
la gran esperanza los jóvenes los niños
el día de ayer yo estuvimos justamente
en una limpieza en una minga que
llamamos nosotros que es un espíritu
colaborativo para rescatar uno de los
ríos que pasa por quito y eso fue
sensacional la organización comunitaria
entonces la esperanza definitivamente
hay plazo y necesitamos educarnos y
estos espacios a ciudadanos pues lo que
tienen que hacer es la fue de flexionar
alrededor de todos estos temas pero nica
y víctor muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros y muchas gracias a ustedes
por la sintonía que en el debate de
france 24 sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]